hello everyone uh this is uh gong
from monster high school for medicine
and thank uh lab roots for organizing
this event and
i'm very happy to present our work uh
today
i titled bacterial epigenomes technology
pathogens and microbial so
this is uh what we are so we we study
epigenetic technologies
and we study epigenetic regulation and
specifically we are
really interested in bacterial and
microbial so a little background on
epigenetics i think
many people know that the information
content of dna is not only on the
primary
sequences of g a t and c but also
there are chemical modifications like d
methylation
and there are also histone modifications
that can change
the gene expression of the same genome
so today we'll mainly focus on
dna so in addition to the canonical
basis
gatc one of the most widely studied form
of
chemical modification is
what we call the methylation but
specifically is the methyl group
is added to the fifth position of
cytosine as shown on the bottom uh
right of the of the slice so this is
vitamin c
and is widely studied for multiple
reasons because
it's playing very important role
in both the healthy development and the
disease
so and in particular in disease as shown
on this slide is
in the context of lung cancer not only
the methylation levels can tell apart
the normal healthy individuals from the
the cancer patients
but you can see the different subtypes
of lung cancer also shows very different
kind of
methylation patterns so this is a very
widely uh
study fibonacci in chart
but if we step back a little bit and see
vibrancy in the whole universe of
the chemical modifications is only one
small piece of the whole uh picture
because right on cytosine there are
uh there could be other kind of chemical
modifications
for example there could be five hydroxy
methyl cytosine
and the methyl group can also occur on
the fourth
base of uh position a fourth position of
cytosine
which we call 4mc
and beyond cytosine the methyl group can
also be added to
adenine and one widely started form is
called the 6
ma and if we further expand the scope
beyond
methylation into other forms of chemical
modifications
there are really uh many many different
kind of chemical
modifications for example uh the
different kind of damages
either response to oxidation uv light or
smoking
and some of them are uh
kind of very uh likely and can cause
disease
but today we will merely talk about
three
forms of methylation as shown here which
is 5mt
4mc and 6ma because
these three are the primary forms of the
methylation that comprise
the bacterial methyl
let's take a closer look at these three
forms of the methylations
and here they are and uh recall that
valency on the right
is well static in most human
and in some other eukaryotes but the
other two
six-man pharmacy we have very limited
understandings despite
that 6-may is actually the most
prevalent form of the methylation in
bacteria
so uh we want to uh maybe
we want to ask the question so why
bacteria want to have
the imagination to start with and this
is related to one of
the topic of this session on immunology
so for bacteria can also get
infected by virus and the bacteria need
to have
a very robust immune system to to
protect themselves
and one way is to uh
one simple model is type two enzymes
in as illustrated in indi in this plot
one enzyme called microtransferase in
short emptiness
this enzyme can put methylated uh
marks across the genome
on specific sequence sites
and when this is done if there's a virus
or
phage get into the dna into the
bacterial cell
then another enzyme called the
restriction uh
enzyme or on the nucleus can recognize
the dna the foreign dna
and cut it if it is not methylated at
the same
sequence site so this is a very simple
uh but very effective way to um protect
the bacteria from
a battery infection and uh a lot of
people
uh probably know uh another system
called
crispr cas9 that's another immune system
of bacterial
which is small like a adaptive immune
system while this
uh restriction modification system or
called rm system
is more like an innate in your system of
bacteria so with this model in mind
let's take another closer a look
there are different kind of arm systems
in bacteria
but they all share a common pattern
of mechanism which has some enzymes
will put the mark on the host the
bacterial dna
was some other corresponding enzymes
like restriction enzymes
will cut a dna at certain motif sites
if it is not methylated as illustrated
in this figure
there's three systems and each of them
have their own unique
sequence contacts so by maculating
very precisely these sites of the
bacterial genome dna it provide a
way to differentiate between foreign dna
and the bacteria
but this is very important for the next
slide
that the concept that i would like to
introduce which is
the stable nature of vector epigenomes
so
why do we call it stable nature is that
as shown in this circle's plot all over
the back your genome
there are some highly methylated motif
sites
or sequence motif sites and for these
motif sites
mostly over 95 percent of the size of
metal in it
why is because it is not methylated
effect effectively then the bacteria's
only restriction enzyme will cut is omg
which is definitely not a good thing to
have
so that's why the bacteria genome
has to maintain a relatively
stable maximization pattern all across
the genome
at particular motif sites so if this is
the case
now let's uh think about about another
scenario because we have two bacterial
genomes that mix together right and in
the context of microbiome
and if uh we want to sequence the genome
of if we want to think of the meta
genome of the microbiome symbol
then essentially we're mixing the the d
together
but how do we separate them and assemble
their interview genomes together into a
a particular string of bacteria if we
look at this figure
and bearing the the concept of
methylation pattern in mind
by eye we can tell okay there are two
different kinds of methylation patterns
in this mixture and we can just separate
them by this methylated pattern
and by the way the circle small circles
uh on the bottom they are plasmids
that are also very prevalent in bacteria
so this looks uh a kind of simple and
it's very simple concept that
i use another slide to introduce uh is
the biology
analogy is just like a pizza so we often
use this example
that uh different toppings of pizza is
uh can be considered as uh methylation
sequence motifs and by eye is very easy
to accept
them from each other so you can imagine
different slices of pizza
represent different part
context of the vector genome that can be
grouped together
even from a mixture so
this sounds great but how do we actually
detect the imagination
especially 6ma 4mc and valencia from the
vector genome
with this question it comes to we need
better and more advanced
technology because second generation
sequencing
technology that is widely used like
illumina
and iron tyrant they cannot directly
detect
these three forms of de-methylation
however
the in the past decade i think there are
their new technology uh cut third
generation sequencing
uh as uh the major players
for example uh uh specific biosciences
technology and also the outside
non-report technology they provide very
exciting technology opportunity to
detect these modifications
i will mainly talk about one of them in
this talk which is
called single molecule real-time
sequencing so
in this technology
um the the dm polymer is is monitored in
real time
and during uh dna synthesis so the name
polymerase is reading one strand of dna
as the template
and as soon as one nucleotide got
incorporated
then the florences will get a flash and
you will see different colors for a t c
and g and by these fluorescents you can
call different bases
using tiny cameras and also in higher
throughput
so as you see you can see from the
bottom uh trace
what we call the trace figure as you can
see over time
you see different colors and from these
different colors we call
the the base of the dna molecule um
but but the most exciting thing in this
type technology is you not only see
these different colors that you can call
the base but you also see
how long the gaps between the
consecutive bases
which we call inter pulse duration
why that's important i will show you on
this slide is
it can actually form the uh presents or
absence of different
forms of the modifications in this plot
you can see there are two
traces and they have exactly the same
dna sequence
the only exception is that one of the
base is
methylated on a on the top
panel but on the bottom panel that's a
regular a
and as you can see the the inter pause
duration
or we call ipd is much longer when
that a is methylated so it's almost like
a speed bump when you have a methylation
then the impulse takes longer to
translocate
from one base to the next one so
uh and by making use of this information
we can calculate
an ipd ratio and this very precisely uh
uh inform the present absence of
the methylation and estrogen in this
case is the 6ma
methylation so with this in mind we
about eight years ago we published the
first study that
mapped the complete bacterial uh
adenine methylation map for bacterial
genomes and today there's already uh
more than two thousand bacterial
methanols that have been mapped
basically given one genome you can tell
all the methylation motifs
from this bacterial strain
and beauty on this concept than
one very talented uh future students in
the in
the group uh john uh kind of
develop a a uh bring the technology
development into another level which is
we want to use these d-metal
motifs as natural epigenetic barcodes
for methylation meaning of metagenomic
or microbial samples and it's natural
because
we don't this barcode is already uh
written
on these spectral genomes by nature
because they need to defend
themselves from phage infection um
and it's epigenetic barcode because
that's not sequence but
the imagination so when we started
we first tried it on a mock community in
which there are only eight
bacterial species as shown here
represent different colors
of each row and each row means a
metagenomic antique
so and each column is uh uh
a methylation motif so and the the the
intensity of each of the color
the darker and is is is is methylated
and if it's
white that means it's not methylated so
by eye we can already tell
that these different bacterials can can
be grouped together very nicely
into uh very accurate
interview genomes only looking at
the methylation pattern so this this was
encouraging
and one way convert the the the product
in
you know another way it's just provide
provide a different way to visualize
different kind of bacterial they cluster
very well by a methylation pattern
so building on this uh encouraging
results on um the mach mock community we
try a real gut microbiome
from a mouse simple and
uh and uh similarly we we're directly
using the method
pattern alone we can group different
genomes
from this macrogram sample as you can
see by these
dashed line rectangles and
it is worth highlighting that out of
these nine genomes
that are directly clustered by
methylation seven of them
come from the bacteria dels uh specific
family
s24-7 this family of bacteria
are widely known to be associated with a
different kind of human diseases
but they are very hard to study because
their genomes
have very similar sequences from with
each other
so but from this analysis we can tell
that
uh even though they have very similar
sequence but they
really have a very different kind of
methylation pattern
so uh this provides a really great
opportunity
that we can have a higher resolution
analysis of microbiome samples
in uh disease association study
and another add-on uh bonus of this
method is that
we can also associate these mobile
genetic elements like plasmid
directly with the the host the genome
that they come from
also by looking at the dna methods
patterns because within the individual
bacterial cell
the chromosome and the plasmids all
share the same
methylation pattern and that is a
methylated pattern we can
link different uh plasmids to different
bacterial host genomes
and in this case in being number one we
find two uh uh
mobile genetic elements one plasmid and
another one is
contradictive transposon and here's
another case
in being eight we find three uh mobile
genetic elements two blocks plasmid and
another
one is the other one is a transposon
so uh with this one uh this basically
opens a new way that people can
more widely uh study
categorize macaron samples at higher
resolution
than previously uh possible so this was
exciting and we'll keep
studying this dimension to summarize the
first component of my
presentation we
the methylation assisted microbial
analysis
in essentially build on the stable
nature
of uh the bacterial epigenomes
because these motifs are highly stable
but we now we want to switch here and
talk about the other property of
bacterial epigenomes which is the
dynamic nature
so why is dynamic because even though
the
methylation motif is largely stable so
that the bacteria can protect itself
from phage infection
there are some low fraction percentage
of sites
that are indeed kept not methylated why
is the case is because by methylating
or non-methylating different sites
in vector genomes especially in promoter
regions
bacterial genes can be turned on or off
accordingly
and by this mechanism it provides
bacterial cells
more flexibility to even generate a
different kind of
methylation patterns and gene expression
patterns and phenotypic
traits even from a colonobacterial
that does not necessarily need to have
different kind of genome
genomic sequence sequence changes
so about nine years ago there was a
famous
e coli outbreak and the the scientists
uh all over the world were reasoning to
to better understand this automatic
strain
try to see what are the unique uh
features
of this upgrade outbreak ecology now
but at that time we asked a different
question which is
let's see what are the methylation the
epigenome
of this uh object strain
maybe there's some unique differential
patterns from the other
isolates because that may contribute to
the
virulence of this e coli uh
hydrating strain and it turned out that
indeed
this uh metal this
up a brick string has a unique method
transfers that we
really don't see from many many other e
coli
uh previous isolates all of the word
and then we hypothesized that
even though this is only a single gene
a single method transfer transferase but
it can
actually put on thousands of metals
marks
all over the bacterial genome of this
outbreak stream
and maybe is playing very important role
uh irregularity in the gene expression
of e-coli
and it turned out to be indeed the case
uh in collaboration with matt watersland
at harvard medical school and because
one way not called the medical transfer
is and the associated
restriction gene we we saw that
over a thousand genes are differentially
expressed uh in the mutant strain this
is
almost represent about 20 of
the total number of genes of e coli so
this was
pretty uh surprising which means these
methylate
these methylation uh events in bacterial
not only protect um
the the bacteria from foreign dna
infection
as traditional traditionally i believe
they also
play a functionally a regulatory role
in bacteria so and
building on this we further examine the
phenotypically
this outbreak strain if we not cognitive
transference
then there's a defect in growth and uh
in another similar study but on a
different kind of pathogen which is
vibro
chloride the pathogen for cholera uh we
saw that not
knocking out a uh a vitamin c in metal
transphase have
about 10 fold reduction on the variance
of
this cholera pathogen
but i really want to talk about today is
a more recent study which is
on clostridium difficile this is a
very uh kind of a nasty pathogen because
a lot of people in immune compromised or
elderly
and they under gone either solid organ
transplantation or maybe eicu or they
have a lot of antibiotics
treatment for a variety of reasons
this pathogen will will become like
overgrown and
pretty deadly so a lot of research has
been done
on this pathogen but mainly focused on
is genome basically the dna sequence but
we
similarly we want to ask a question
what's
what's going on in his epigenome is
there some demethylation patterns
that could be very important to know so
that we can better battle
with this uh critical pathogen so in
this
study we um at monster science of
medicine we played about
40 isolates of cdf
and we mapped their metal methylone just
like what i presented earlier for all
the uh
pathogens and and in this plot each row
is a
it's an isolate of c diff and each
column is a
methylation pattern that we discovered
from
each of the isolates and by eye you can
tell that the second column from the
left
is always red which means every single
athlete
of cdf has a methylation motif as you
show here is c
a a a a so basically c and 5 a and we're
very
excited when we saw this and especially
later when we find that
there's actually a meta transfer is
responsible or
funded for this mathematician um
motif and this method transfers is
highly conservative
in every single city of athletes all
over the world and
so far we didn't find any exception
across even thousands of isolates
so beyond this discovery we started to
collaborate with amy chen's lab
in uh tufts medical school and
amy's team not called this method
transfers
and initially we only see about half of
uh
like a reduction uh in spiral relation
which is the
critical phenotype of cdf because they
need to form a spark
to transmit and and also for recurrence
in patients
but this two-fold reduction was not so
dramatic
uh in actually and later we uh
further collaborated with another lab
had by uh rita tamayo in uh
unc and when we use uh animal model we
were
very uh kind of uh excited to find
there's actually about a hundred fold
reduction
uh if we uh knock out this method
transfers in cdf
so it means the functional importance of
this method transfers is more
pronounced in evil in a god environment
so and beauty on this we further
examined
so why methylation uh can regulate
or impact spirallation
and because spherulation is very complex
process uh in cdf because
it's a kind of different phase and
regular by different uh
master regulators so i'll keep the story
uh short
in this essentially by examining a time
course gene expression patterns and also
by uh
the master regulation uh regular regular
regulator
uh analysis we find that we're not
narrowed down to two
um sigma factors which is sig e and sig
f
that we think they are mediating the
epigenetic epigenetic regulation
of spinal spirallation in dc death
so okay so this is uh with this
i will uh pretty much conclude by
emphasizing the two
important features of bacterial
epigenomes one is the stable nature
at the motif level it's highly motif
driven and we can
exploit this unique feature to a better
and categorized samples at a higher
resolution
as i shown in the first first half of
this presentation
and uh but the other nature which is
dynamic nature is more functionally uh
related and we're characterizing
epidural regulation in different
material especially in pathogens because
we want to
see whether we can develop novel
therapeutics building on this better
understanding
of spiral nation uh incident and maybe
some
violence in other pathogens
and and this is again our our team
and as uh you recall from the pizza
pizza example
and we we really uh like bacterial uh
epigenome research because it's
essentially it's very tasty like they've
animated different kind of toppings
uh not like uh standard pizza maybe just
like a few toppings and it's very
exciting
and let us know if you are interested
and finally the acknowledge page
is this works i covered multiple
studies and uh by uh
the lab members in our group and also
our colleagues in the genomics
department
and our multiple collaborators imagine
blazers lab in new york
university and now in rutherford uh
rutgers medical school
and matt waters lab in hubbard med
school
emissions lab in tufts university and
rich roberts
group in uh new england by labs
and uh right at meyer's lab in uh
north carolina and funding agencies
so that's all thank you